so our last speaker for today is Raj
Kumar he's going to be talking with us
about Material Science and Engineering
so I encourage you to think about how
you might use chemistry and various
sorts of Engineering in materials
science engineering what's sort of the
interface between all these things might
be
all right did everyone hear me okay
awesome well thank you so much for the
introduction yeah my name is Raj Kumar
I'm a lecturer and the director of
undergraduate studies in our Materials
Science and Engineering Department it's
really nice to be here in person last
couple times we've done this for
engineering one students it's been on
Zoom so it's a lot nicer I think to be
in front of you all here today and kind
of following up from some of the
comments earlier I have a quick poll
before you enrolled in this class
raise your hand if you had ever heard of
what Materials Science and Engineering
is
wow okay this is getting better and
better every year looks like maybe half
or a little more than half which is
great for all of you who didn't have
your hand raise that was me
when I was uh my first quarter of
undergrad I had no idea what material
science and engineering is so like many
of you I was in your shoes and I ended
up kind of finding this major and
getting really excited about it so I'll
just take a few minutes to kind of
explain why it might be for you just a
quick overview since several of you
hadn't heard of what material science
and engineering is all about what we
really care about is understanding how
the structure of the materials that we
use all the time influence the
properties that we care about
so what do I mean by structure what I
mean by properties Well turns out that
the way that individual atoms are
arranged or groups of atoms create a
nanostructure or what the chemical
structure might be or the electronic
structure of a material might be
dramatically influences how it performs
mechanically electrically chemically
biology biologically thermally Etc
and if we can tune what the structure of
those materials are and we can
characterize what that structure
actually is
then we can set what its properties and
ultimate performance might be
okay conversely as an engineer which I
am which is really fun and we get to do
we get to say well you know wouldn't it
be great if my iPhone could be charged
once a week instead of once a day or my
electric vehicle could drive a thousand
miles instead of 300 miles right that's
what's called a performance Benchmark
and if we set some goals and means
approach of kind of looking at Material
Science and Engineering we can figure
out and back kind of track what are the
properties what is the structure and
what is the way we can process materials
to get to that Benchmark to achieve our
our goals that we care about
so this is the approach that we take
regardless of if we're interested in
designing better batteries we're
designing Healthcare Technologies uh
we're designing novel electronic
structures and devices all sort of
fields of Material Science and
Engineering touch a lot of the different
applications that we care about in
society so when you might ask the
question where is Material Science and
Engineering I could tell you physically
where it is on campus not too far from
here but I think what matters more is
where it touches all of the different
amazing applications that Stanford
students and faculty get to work on and
get to really tackle so regardless if
you're interested in materials for
energy storage materials for computing
and electronics biomedical devices
medical Diagnostics manufacturing and
many many other topics and disciplines
we do research and we collaborate and
connect with others on campus to solve
some of these really important Grand
challenges in science and engineering so
I want to walk through just two quick
applications with you today I would walk
through so many more because I think
they're really exciting but in the short
amount of time I'll just have two for
you today so on the topic of batteries
that John already brought up just a
moment ago if you look at the the
battery pack that's in a Tesla or the
battery that's in your smartphone or
laptops that you have in front of you uh
who can tell me what's the ion that's
traveling back and forth in the battery
lithium yes lithium all of the batteries
we use are lithium ion batteries that's
right okay and so if you take apart that
that battery pack uh that John showed
for the iPhone and you take a look at
the negative electrode that's called the
anode it will look something like this
okay it has a copper typically current
collector which is just this big block
film and it has this porous composite
that's made of carbon and a polymeric
binder that kind of sticks things
together and a few other additives in
there as well and this is what allows
sort of lithium to shuttle back and
forth from anode to cathode to charge
and discharge that battery that's in
your smartphone and your laptop in your
electric vehicle
so it turns out that lithium is right
the third element on the periodic table
we saw the periodic table a few moments
ago
um in lithium that means it's a really
really small ion okay it's really hard
to see how do you see lithium well it
turns out there's these set of
techniques known as x-ray
characterization techniques that allow
us to visualize the movement of ions
back and forth so I have a little bit of
a video here this is uh courtesy a
professor will Chu a faculty in our
department his group does a lot of
cutting edge research on new battery
technologies and what they were
interested in this study was seeing does
the shape of these carbon particles
those are the ones that store the
lithium lithium essentially stack in
between the layers of carbon is there a
sort of relationship between the size
and the shape of these particles and how
lithium ends up going in and out to
charge and discharge the battery
so what you're seeing here is that these
carbon particles are fully lithiated
okay they have sort of superset or
saturated with lithium
and as this battery essentially is run
we can see the lithium leaving in each
of these individual particles to the
point where at the end all the lithium
has been extracted and removed
okay
anybody notice anything curious
about this picture
anyone
yeah different shapes the green and
bearing rates and none of the very end
of those platform yeah varying rates and
then they all sort of go away at the end
and what you'll notice as well it's an
excellent observation what you'll also
notice right is that
the lithium doesn't get removed
continuously across the entire particle
right there are hot spots right certain
spots go green first
so what that means is that there are
preferential sites for lithium to leave
these carbon particles and with this
showed Professor Chu's team is that if
you tailor the surface structure or the
morphology of these carbon particles
maybe there's a way to make it easier
for lithium ions to shuttle back and
forth
what could that lead to well potentially
batteries that charge and discharge more
efficiently and so that when you go to
your charging station maybe instead of
an hour to charge only takes 10 minutes
or something like that right so this was
a initial study that they've really
worked on a lot more in the last few
years to show that the structure of the
things that go inside our battery anodes
have a key impact on their properties
and performance of those batteries that
we care about
okay so one more example that I want to
quickly go through is uh I I again my
background is in in batteries and energy
materials but over the last few years
like many of you I've gotten really
interested in biology and really
interested in healthcare especially and
so uh several of our faculty in our
apartment work on materials for health
care for health diagnostics for uh bio
medical implants and many other
applications and so one of these
applications comes from Professor gosong
Hong's lab where his group is really
interested at trying to probe the brain
and trying to understand how do those
neural functions in our brain really
work and it turns out that has a lot of
important applications in
neurodegenerative diseases okay so I I
have a family member with Alzheimer's
and so that's a big important thing for
me to understand and think about and so
the idea is well what if we could create
probes that go dry directly into our
brain
now it turns out in order to do that we
need probes that essentially match the
mechanical properties of your brain
tissue and your brain's kind of soft so
if you stick an electronic probe or a
needle in that it's going to be a little
bit of a problem so what if we design
conductors
that are as soft as water
and can float so this is an example of
injectable copper films
that can actually be injected into the
brain and monitor electronic activity so
you can measure neural activity and
maybe figure out something along the
lines of what sort of is going wrong
when we have these neurodegenerative
diseases what is the impact in our
neural function
with the sort of broader idea that
eventually you could create these
networks of injectable sort of copper
probes and really understand again what
the overall function is of the brain to
treat disease and potentially even
regain motor function for folks who
suffer from paralysis or other you know
loss of spinal or neural activity as
well
so these are just two examples of where
Material Science and Engineering shows
up there are many many more and
unfortunately I can't talk to you all
about them today but I would love to so
come stop by and chat with me really
really briefly our department is a
department of 22 faculty about 40
undergraduates many many more graduate
students and we have lots of different
classes offered throughout the year and
I think what makes this great is our
department culture really combines
everyone together we have lots of
different events where you see faculty
graduate students postdocs undergrads
all together and getting to to chat
about some of the things that they're
passionate about and interested in
we have a really vibrant undergraduate
community so hopefully I think these
slides will get shared later so you
don't have to write any of these links
down but we have a great undergraduate
student organization sums that puts on
study nights uh guest speaker and
different industry tours and other great
events for you to learn more about our
department culture meet some of our
fellow students and get connected to our
broader sort of materials community
uh this question I get asked a lot where
do mad SCI Majors go and the answer
really is everywhere and anywhere
whether you're interested in going into
big companies like Intel and SpaceX and
Tesla and apple they're interested in
working at startup Ventures and again
the biomedical space the energy space
the electronic Computing space I'm going
to graduate school working at National
Labs education public policy we have
students go everywhere and anywhere so a
material science and engineering degree
can really take you to a lot of great
places
we have some great courses offered for
students who are interested in just
checking out what is Material Science
and Engineering so one of them that I'm
going to highlight briefly right now is
maths I-10 but there's many others out
there
mats I-10 is a class that actually I
teach this fall and it's a way maybe
some of you are already enrolled in the
class which is great but it's a way for
you to learn more about where are the
career opportunities in Material Science
and Engineering and and I talked earlier
about how our major is really
interdisciplinary
and that really shows from the speakers
that we invite they talk routinely about
whether they work in the fields of
energy and sustainability biomaterials
regenerative medicine atomic scale sort
of engineering for electronics and
nanotechnology they work with so many
different other Engineers scientists
technologists economists Business
Leaders as well to make The Cutting Edge
technologies that we rely on every day
and that we hope to to bring here in the
near future to help solve again some of
these really important challenges
last thing I want to kind of end with is
a lot of our students really get really
take a liking to getting involved in
research while they're here at Stanford
I think it's research is a great way to
supplement your learning and classes by
getting to do things that are Hands-On
and getting some really great
opportunities to work with graduate
students and faculty on some of these
Cutting Edge problems that I briefly
talked about
so we have a great uh matzai Ru program
which is over the summer you get paid to
come do research at Stanford over the
summer and get to work in a cohort of
about 20 of your peers on a really a
wide variety of different research
topics and we recently started last year
this undergraduate research grants
program this urg program so this is a
way to get paid to do research in the
winter and spring quarter for about 10
hours a week or so for the two quarters
happy to chat about you chat with you
about that in the in the Q a
okay so really quick
why did I choose Material Science and
Engineering
remember I told you I took an intro
level course on scanning electron
microscopes
these are the pictures that I took as an
18 year old that I got to actually see
what a vinyl record looks like under an
electron microscope this is a vinyl
record so if you are into like 70s audio
media and have a vinyl collection this
is what it looks like at the sort of
Micron scale and this is the shiny side
of a compact disc okay so the back side
so this shows you how we read and write
data on a compact disc
so is being able to get to see what
these sort of traditional materials that
you see you know with your eyes on a
daily scale what they look like deep
down and how it informs how we make
these structures to impact the
properties and performance that we use
on these materials every single day and
by getting involved in Matt's eye I was
really exposed to an interdisciplinary
way of thinking which I think really
matters in solving some again these
Cutting Edge problems and that we face
today
so with that these are some reasons why
you might choose a Material Science and
Engineering I'm happy to talk about that
a little bit more thank you so much for
your attention really appreciate it